hello everyone here on the free codecamp
channel today
my name is anu kubo and i'm a software
developer as well as course creator
online in this online course i'll be
talking to you about the differences
between the terms sql and nosql when it
comes to databases as well as which kind
of database you use when and why
in this course we are going to go back
to basics and look at what exactly a
database is and how it's defined we're
then going to look at database design
and why it's important what a database
management system is we'll then look at
relational databases followed by an sql
crash course we will then move on to
look at non-relational databases
followed by sql vs nosql as well as the
pros and cons of using relational
databases versus non-relational ones we
will finish off with some use cases and
then a nosql crash course and don't
worry you'll leave this course with a
much better idea of when to use what
database technology
before we dive into the types of
databases that exist let's talk about
why they matter to your career as a
developer
data is an important part of it
without data computers and even the
internet would be a pretty uninteresting
place
if you are aiming to become an
application or full site developer
databases are your friend the market
today pretty much expects fluency with a
relational model but there is an upside
here according to stackoverflow's recent
surveys nosql skills can really help
differentiate you from the pack for
example in their 2021 survey the top
four top paying database salaries were
all nosql databases dynamodb
elasticsearch cassandra and redis
so go grab a hot beverage roll up your
sleeves and let's get started if you
think the ranger choices are a little
overwhelming now just wait until you get
into the universe of javascript
programming so what are we waiting for
let's get to it by the way this course
is brought to you by data stacks if
you'd like to follow along with code
examples you can sign up for the data
such as db free plan and a few clicks if
you want a deep dive into relational and
non-relational databases after the
course check out the intro to sql course
and the introduction to nosql course
right here on the free codecamp channel
now let's start with taking a moment to
go back to basics and talk through what
exactly a database is a database is a
systematic collection of data in the
world of computing this collection of
data can be accessed electronically
you can access it electronically to get
data add data delete data or update data
small databases can usually be stored on
a file system on a simple storage device
this can be something like a sd card a
hard drive or a usb
larger databases on the other hand while
in the past on mainframes or beefy
individual servers are usually hosted
today on computer clusters or cloud
storage
a file system is essentially something
that lives on a storage device such as a
hard drive it defines how files are
named stored and retrieved
for example imagine you are using your
laptop which is a mac and you plug in
your storage device or hard drive which
contains data into your mac in order to
retrieve a file that you put on it
now without any kind of file system
implemented your max operating system
won't be able to find the data that you
are looking for it would all be a big
mess essentially
file systems bring in order this is the
same for computer clusters on which
large databases are usually hosted on
now so far we have looked at the example
of one hard drive but what if you have
way more data than we can fit on this
tiny little hard drive what if you need
10 hard drives what if you need 10
computers or more
this is what a computer cluster is you
are essentially linking a bunch of
computers together across a network to
work as one
a cluster can be viewed as a single
system or in other words one computer
clusters can be grouped together under
one control plane which is what manages
connecting all the computers together
and the outside communications
fun fact the first computer database was
sabre the airline reservation system the
process for reservations outgrew the
paper card system they used and ibm came
up with a new solution in the 1960s to
help scale up operations at american
airlines
so
that is how we can store our databases
so on a file system for small databases
and things such as computer clusters for
large databases
but what about databases themselves how
are they organized
this is all down to database design
there are many ways a database can be
designed heck you could even design your
own database if you really wish all
you'd need to do is decide on a database
model
a database model will determine exactly
how you want your data to look and not
only that but how you want it to
interact with other data
for example you may have a database
model that follows the idea of a table
this will mean that all your data has to
fit in the structure
now if i'm collecting data on how well
each student did as a specific subject
in terms of grades then a table would be
great however what if i also then decide
i want to add how much the student
enjoyed the subject then this table
would not work we would have to redesign
our database and perhaps use a different
database model perhaps a document model
would work better
this is why database design is so
important and has to be thought of early
on in any project
here are just some examples of database
models as you can see there's a lot we
will go into the most popular ones like
the relational model document model
white column and key value model and how
they define the modern database
landscape first off though let's talk
about how developers interact with these
databases
a database management system or dbms is
a way for us to essentially communicate
with our database
think of it as a layer or interface
between the data and our little fingers
on the keyboard it allows us to get
existing data create new data update
data and delete data from our database
we have our data in our database here
then we have the dbms and then we have
the end user great any given database
management system may provide one or
more models we'll talk about the
multi-modal databases briefly at the end
and for this tutorial we are going to
use a cloud database since they all
usually provide a free plan or tier and
it's much faster than downloading
installing and configuring it
then we can just focus on the code and
core concepts i use astrodb a lot so
i'll be using it since it allows me to
create different types of nosql
databases in one place then i'm not
switching platforms all the time during
the course
however you don't have to use it there
are plenty of other database management
systems out there some only deal with
one type and some are multi-modal which
we'll talk about again later on
here is a list of some popular dbms you
will come across as a developer
now i'm going to show you what a typical
cloud database experience is like these
days to get started with astrodb sign up
for free just go ahead and do the
process of that by clicking on the sign
up to try astra for free button
once here i want you to sign up i'm
going to go ahead and sign in as i've
already created an account for this
wonderful
here is the dashboard we are on the free
current plan which is more than enough
for research and development work
without being prompted for a credit card
so what we're going to have to do is
create our first database just go ahead
and click the button and it will take
you to this page once on here let's name
our database something i'm going to call
this tutorial as it is for tutorial
purposes and the schema name or as
apache cassandra calls them key spaces
now we're going to create a few key
spaces the first one we create is going
to be called wide column as it's going
to be for creating a wide column
database
let's go ahead and do that now we're
going to select a provider and region
again i'm just going to choose the one
closest to me so this will be mumbai
india and let's go ahead and click
create
next you'll see this page show up in
which we're going to be given all our
tokens and necessary things to
communicate with our database so here's
what it looks like just copy all of this
and make sure to keep it somewhere safe
for the upcoming tutorial and go ahead
and click on the go to database button
great
at the moment this is pending we are
going to have to wait for this to be
active before we can use it but as soon
as it's active you will see the status
change to active so great we know this
is active because we can see options
such as connect cql and more in the tabs
above and we have our first key space
which is white column under the word key
spaces below
we could also add more schema or key
spaces as they are called in cassandra
which we will be doing later see
much easier than downloading installing
and configuring it just so you can play
with some code
most cloud databases are pretty similar
in how to create a database so you can
start coding straight away
wonderful let's move on
now that we know how to get set up with
our dbms let's get into talking about
the different types of databases we
could have
the first thing we are going to look at
is the relational database we are going
to do this in order to understand the
differences between sql and nosql
but to get to that point we still have a
little bit of knowledge to cover and
what better place to start than looking
at the most familiar and most strongly
consistent database in my eyes which is
the relational database
as we now know databases depend on their
design and what type of models they use
relational databases provide a store of
related data tables these tables have a
fixed schema use sql or the structure
query language to manage data and
support asset guarantees
in general rdbms assumes you can
structure your data and trades off the
strongest consistency guarantees and
ease of use for ensuring consistency
with scalability volume and availability
there is a great deep dive on how to
design a relational database right here
on youtube if you want to learn more
popular open source examples here are
mysql postgres and mariadb
the relational database uses that
relational model and looks something
like this kind of a table with columns
and rows are linked together if we wish
usually each table has some kind of
theme going on or in other words entity
type just like we saw with the grades
for our students before
in that instance each row has a student
and each column was a class topic
in relational databases each row has a
unique identifier so we can pick it out
thanks to this unique identifier we can
now also link these rows or students to
other tables such as this one which each
student's enjoyment level of topic we
can even take this one step further to
really clean up and take out the names
of the students and put them in a third
table now all the data we want to be
linked is linked thanks to the id number
these links are called foreign keys and
relational design
sounds simple right
now i'm going to show you how to create
your own using sql for creating clearing
and maintaining databases i'm going to
be showing you how to do this with some
slides sql or the structured query
language is a language that became
prominent in the late 1970s for managing
data and relational database management
systems it's worth noting that while
ansi sql does indeed define a standard
syntax each rdbms has some subtle
platform specific considerations some of
them in the syntax of the code outside
the standard anci sql specifications and
some in how the sql query execution
engine functions at runtime many also
have wholly proprietary extensions for
more advanced features
now let's see what creating a schema and
table in an sql database is like
let's try a simple example together
here is what the syntax for sql looks
like for example to create a student
table of grades we would use a statement
this statement is create table
after this statement we then define what
we want to choose to call our table
i'm going to choose to call it student
grades
next we define our columns
on this occasion we will define column 1
as the id
column 2 as the name column 3 as the
subject math column 4 as the subject art
and column 5 as the subject geography we
also need to find the type that goes
into each column
for example we can have varchar integer
date and much more
we are going to define our id column as
taking integers our name column as
varchar so it takes characters or text
and for the other columns we are going
to put varchar as well as we want to put
8 out of 10.
if you'd like to just put in an 8
however you could choose to use integers
instead
we can also define a primary key the
primary key constraint uniquely
identifies each record in a table
in this example we will want our id to
be that unique identifier
primary keys must contain unique values
and cannot contain null values
finally we put in the semicolon and the
statement and press enter
great
now that we have defined our table let's
get to putting data into the table that
we have just made
to put in data into our table we use two
statements insert into and values the
full statement would look like this we
would use the command insert into and
then we will use whatever we decide to
call our table in this case it was
student grades
and then we will rewrite the column
names that we want to put data into i'm
just going to put in all of them
on the next line i'm going to use the
values command to insert data into those
columns
and of course we need a semicolon to end
this statement
inserted one line into our database but
how do we actually look at our database
well for this there's a very simple
command we use the command select
followed by a star which means all
from our table called student grades
okay
so
great now let's test it out for this i'm
going to use the sql playground on
w3schools and all i'm going to do is
literally paste in the commands that we
wrote before
so we need to create a table first so
here we are creating a table called
student grades with an id name math art
and geography column as well as defining
our primary key and hitting run sql
okay so that has now been added to our
database the next thing we need to do is
add in our
line
so add in some data so i'm going to
delete this and just use this command so
this is going to insert into student
grade it's going to insert the id the
name of the student the math the art and
geography scores so let's run that as
you can see changes have been made to
the database run row has been affected
and now to get the data well we use
select all
from and whatever we called the table
which is student
grades
and you will see our table with the id
the name the score the student got for
maths art and geography
wonderful
so that was a quick crash course about
making relational databases using sql
let's continue
now this is not an sql tutorial i'm
simply giving you a very quick crash
course and how to use it for the purpose
of this tutorial
sql has a lot to offer and is a very
well thought out language that takes a
while to learn
if you would like to deep dive into the
topic after this course then please do
check out some tutorials on this that we
have on free coca
so we now have a good idea about what a
relational database looks like and how
we can manage data in it using sql the
structured query language
but there are also such things as
non-relational databases and there are a
few of them
we are not going to look at all of them
we're simply going to look at the three
most popular ones
so we are going to look at the wide
column database type the document
database type that uses the document
model and the key value database type
which you guessed it uses the key value
model
all of these non-relational databases
are commonly referred to as nosql
databases and whilst you might be
thinking ah so they do not use sql the
structure query language that we just
learnt you would be totally wrong
nosql means not only structured query
language which allows you to use the
language or not use it to get the data
and it's considered to be an approach to
database management
nosql's appearance on the scene is noted
as somewhere around the 2000s
so if we compare this on a table you
will see here that under sql i put an
icon to represent a relational database
as we can use sql to query relational
databases we now know that we can also
use sql to query some non-relational
databases
or at least the ones that offer
relational as a secondary database model
and a sql interface anyway
nosql uses different query languages for
key value document and tabular or white
column and so on
now when people look at nosql and sql
they might be tempted to compare the two
but by now we know we can't do this
why
this is because sql is a database
management approach and sql is a query
language so two completely different
things
it might be better going forward to
start referring to nosql databases as
non-relational databases
so let's go ahead and switch that so we
can compare them to relational databases
from now on
okay great
so now that we have that down let's look
at the pros and cons of each
first off let's look at standardized
schema when working with relational
databases you can have the benefit of
schema being standardized for example
imagine i'm working at a pizza
restaurant as a chef and each waiter
instead of showing people menus for
people to pick from started just asking
them what kind of pizza they want you
would have a huge range of pizzas to
make and this would add some level of
difficulty to your job
in this scenario the menu is built using
a pizza schema it comes with a list of
well-known pizzas that people can pick
and you can make
it's the same with data and relational
databases by providing a schema that
everyone's familiar with and used to
using it makes working with relational
databases worldwide a whole lot easier
now
some people might find this rigidity a
con
but in general it's viewed upon
favorably
next up let's look at large user
communities another pro we have is that
relational query languages such as sql
have a larger user community
as sql has been around for nearly 50
years it has a strong community of
supporters as well as a lot of help and
resources out there for learning
purposes
next up is standardized query language
another pro for relational query
languages such as sql is that it's
considered to be quite an easy language
to learn as it uses simple keywords
we use these keywords in managing and
searching through databases
anyone that's worked with spreadsheets
can relate to this model as it's often
covered in university courses
next up we have acid the final pro we
have for relational databases is that
they tend to be acid compliant which
stands for atomicity consistency
isolation and durability you will see
this acronym pop up a lot
this level of compliance keeps tables in
sync and guarantees the validity of
transactions
now let's look at the cons of relational
databases first up is difficulty
clustering the main cons of traditional
databases are that they tend to scale up
vertically
what this means is that the only way to
scale your database is to increase your
ram cpu or ssd on your existing server
or to migrate to a larger more expensive
one altogether you'll need to
continually increase hard drive space as
your data grows and you'll need faster
machines to run evolving and more
sophisticated technologies the database
vendor you'll use will likely require
you to periodically level up your
hardware just to run their latest
releases
in this environment hardware can quickly
become outdated
each upgrade is expensive and resource
intensive most relational database
hardware also needs ongoing everyday
maintenance
next up is data normalization developed
at a time when the cost of data storage
was high relational databases such as
sql ones attempted to negate the data
duplication
each table has different information and
they can be connected and queried using
common values
however as these databases get large the
lookups and joins required between
numerous tables can slow things down and
be too complex to code and debug
next up is schema first
sql relational database schemas must be
defined before use
once in place they are inflexible and
modifications are typically difficult
and have a wide blast radius affecting
both data and application
non-relational databases vary in this
respect
for example document databases do not
require schema up front while they say
wide column does for that reason
substantial time needs to be invested in
upfront planning before the database is
ever put into production so it follows
that they're only appropriate when all
your data is also structured and you
don't expect much change either in
volume or data type
next up is resource intensive scaling
as mentioned earlier relational
databases normally scale vertically by
assigning more resources to the existing
hardware investment
this can be expensive and time consuming
newer relational databases or cloud
services aka new sql can horizontally
scale a relational sql database through
partitioning or sharding
make sure to understand how the addition
of partitioning or sharding for rdbms
affects acid consistency guarantees as
it can be different from non-cluster
deployments
remember that all rdbms or relational
database management systems are subject
to the limitations of cap theorem the
moment a network link is introduced
now that we have covered the pros and
cons of a relational databases let's
look at the pros and cons of
non-relational databases
first up is continuous availability with
non-relational databases data is
distributed across multiple servers and
regions so there is no single point of
failure as a result non-relational
databases are designed to be more stable
and resilient with continuous
availability and zero downtime
particularly with cloud deployments
next up is query speed non-relational
databases are denormalized without worry
or data duplication for example in white
column databases the information needed
for a particular query will often be
stored together no joins required
this makes lookups easier especially
when working with large data volumes
it also means non-relational databases
can be very fast for primary key or
indexed queries
for data without an index however query
speed can taper off as non-relational
databases reach high levels of scale
without the right data model
next up is agility
non-relational databases were developed
as large data storage costs were
beginning to drastically drop and
systems were being distributed and or
deployed on the cloud
data duplication was no longer a concern
non-relational schema are generally
designed to give the developers more
control over database integrity and
schema as well as trade-offs between
consistency availability and performance
there are a variety of different
non-relational approaches
acid-compliant databases hide the
complexity of a very costly operation
and give you no other choices with the
approach to trading of consistency for
performance
also there are times where all those
guarantees of the relational models
simply aren't truly needed most
developers have been conditioned to
reach for the high data integrity
relational model without challenging
themselves to think deeply about where
those guarantees are truly needed
however understanding the data model now
and in the future is arguably the most
important thing so future business
requirements continue to align with the
strengths of the approach you've chosen
agility comes in other forms as well for
example document databases don't have to
have predefined schemas instead they are
dynamic with the ability to handle all
types of data including structured
semi-structured unstructured and
polymorphic data you can skip upfront
database schema definitions and get
right to development
developers can redefine json document
structure anytime and easily add data
types and fields at runtime without
requiring a schema change
all of this makes the nosql approach a
great fit for modern agile development
teams
the flexibility and adaptive nature of
non-relational databases makes them a
great fit for organizations that have a
variety of data types and expect to
continuously add new features and
functionality
non-relational databases are not one
size fits all
unlike the relational databases they
aren't constrained to a single
normalized data model a single approach
to consistency or single approach
indexing in their quest for scalability
and availability at scale
next up we have low cost
non-relational databases scale out
horizontally making it cost effective to
expand capacity rather than upgrading
expensive hardware they can cheaply
expand by simply adding commodity
service or cloud instances
open source non-relational databases
provide affordable options for many
organizations they are a good fit for
cloud computing and handle extremely
large and quickly growing data sets
now let's move on to the cons
next up is no standardized query
language there isn't a standard language
to conduct no sql queries
some like key value databases are so
simple they don't need one
other nosql systems even provide direct
support for ncsql
the syntax used to query data varies for
the different types of non-relational
databases but unlike relational
databases where there is just one easy
to learn language to master nosql has a
steeper learning curve sure each
relational sql execution engine does
certain things a little differently has
proprietary extensions and so on but at
least syntactically they all have the
ansi sql standard syntax in common
for example it might be difficult for a
developer to quickly get up to speed
working on a wide column database if all
their prior experience for example
consists of building and managing graph
databases
however there is an emerging trend to
start exposing databases as de facto or
popular apis it's a helpful alternative
for many developers who are able to
trade off some level of performance for
developer productivity
using database api gateways saves on you
hard coding what would have otherwise
been boilerplate data access code
also using apis like rest craftql json
grpc may already be familiar to many app
developers overcoming some concerns here
about standardization
next up we have the smaller user
community developers have been using
non-relational databases or nosql
databases for more than a decade and the
community is growing quickly however
it's still less mature than the sql
community so it could be harder to solve
undocumented issues
there are also fewer consultants and
experts on the nosql side
next up let's look at developer skills
required flexibility comes with a price
with a variety of approaches found in
non-relational databases there's more to
learn this as we know is unlike learning
how to use sql which is relatively
simple
even the simplest of nosql queries will
still likely require programming
experience or possibly to learn an api
this means more technical and costly
staff like developers or data scientists
we need to perform the queries
next up is data retrieval and
consistency the distributed nature of
non-relational databases enable data to
be available faster however it can also
make it more difficult to ensure the
data is always consistent
queries might not always return updated
data and is possible to receive
unaccurate information
with its distributed approach the
database could return different values
at the same time depending on which
server happens to be queried
this is one of the reasons some
non-relational databases don't achieve
acid level compliance
consistency is the c in acid which
states that the data must be valid and
consistent at the start and end of a
transaction
instead most non-relational databases
adhere to base consistency models
whether e stands for eventual
consistency in other words the data will
be consistent at some point later on
different non-relational databases vary
in their approaches to consistency and
transactions so it's difficult to
generalize
in the real world this is often a very
small delay only of a few milliseconds
so for many applications that likely
won't matter for example social media
posts going live or an online shopping
cart being updated that won't really
matter too much
in those situations lower latency and
high availability outweighs the value of
providing the exact same data at the
exact times uses
however think of when you make an online
stock purchase then it would really
matter
non-relational databases value speed and
availability over consistency compared
to relational databases
each project must decide if that aligns
with their goals
now that we have covered that it's time
for a quick crash course and learning
about some non-relational databases for
a full tutorial on nosql check out the
intro to nosql right here on
freecodecamp
our quick crash course will include
looking at the document database type
the key value database type and the wide
column database type so let's do it
the first one we're going to look at is
the wide column database type
now as astrodb is built on apache
cassandra we're actually going to be
using cql or the cassandra query
language to demonstrate some of the
different approaches to nosql
the cql query language is a subset of
sql so the basic commands we're using
here in this video are exactly the same
okay so just so we understand we are
going to be using cql the query language
which is very similar to sql however
we're going to be using to create a
non-relational database and on this
occasion the non-relational database we
will be using is a wide column database
okay
sounds confusing don't worry we're going
to go into this in a lot more detail
coming up when approaching your
databases choices in general it's
helpful to understand the models for the
concepts behind them that you like to
use as points of comparison
carnage melon's database of databases
provides an excellent much comprehensive
technical resource in this regard but
pragmatically here's a few important
aspects for comparing dbms
in the spectrum of non-relational
databases wide column aka column family
is sort of in the middle of a spectrum
with relational databases on one side
and key value on the other
on one side you have rdbms or relational
database management system and acid dbms
with lots of built-in features and
performance overhead to the much more
simplistic less feature rich but way
faster dbms like key value
popular open source options here include
apache cassandra apache hbase and many
others
they are often used for operational app
database tasks like scaling time series
data e-commerce or inventory management
content management personalization
recommendations fraud detection
transaction logging tracking and many
other right-intensive infrequent update
use cases
wide column stores like apache cassandra
use the notion of column families a
database object that contains multiple
columns of related data that are used
together similar to traditional
relational database management tables
within a given column family all data is
stored in a row by row fashion such as
the columns for a given row are stored
together rather than each column being
stored separately
put another way a column family is the
key value pair where the key is mapped
to a value that is a set of columns
in analogy with the relational databases
a column family is a table
each key value pair being a row
for developers y column tables can
present themselves as a row and column
table that is familiar and easy to work
with in code or apis
understanding how the primary key in y
column database is different from
relational primary keys is essential
followed by proficiency in data modeling
to learn more about both of these i
recommend this course in apache
cassandra as an example
so using apache cassandra as an example
the two biggest differences between y
column databases and relational
databases are why column has partition
and clustering keys relational uses
foreign keys
recently white column databases are
evolving allowing the ability to provide
relational style secondary indexes for
columns outside and even full asset
transactions so the spectrum we just
spoke about is changing over time
learn more about these secondary indices
right here on youtube in the link
showing up
so to look at this encode cql or
cassandra query language is a subset of
ansi sql to compare them this is cql
select syntax using ebnf notation it is
a subset of sql
sql also supports binary operators such
as inner outer joins union accept
intersect nested sub-queries and clause
having
in addition cql restricts what columns
can be used in different clauses
this is the cql create table syntax
using eb and f notation
we can learn some more sql basics right
here on youtube following the link
popping up
okay so here we go let's create some
tables that store data
so in order to do this i'm just going to
click the cql tab up here which will
bring up our cql console
wonderful
now just to check this works i'm just
going to write show host and that should
show us our hosts and next if you want
to check the version i'm just going to
type the commands show version and then
follow with a semicolon to finish off
this statement and hit enter
now any version will support what we've
shown here in the tutorial since we're
just showing straightforward basic
syntax
new commands may be available in newer
versions so it might be worth checking
what version of cql you are using
now the first thing i want to do is just
list out all the key spaces that we have
in this database
so to do this i'm going to use the d e s
c command for describe
key spaces and just hit semicolon again
and that will run that statement and it
will bring up all the key spaces that we
have in our database
so as you can see the wide column key
space that we made earlier is here this
is the one that we want to use for this
part of the tutorial so we need to go
into this key space
now we can do so using another command
which is the use command followed by the
key space name which in this case is
wide column
follow it off with a semicolon to finish
this statement and hit enter so as you
will see we are now in the wide column
key space great
so once again this is the key space we
made previously and that's what we are
in now
now once here it's time for us to start
you guessed it creating some data
creating a table to put in this key
space
so to do this you guessed it we're going
to use the create
table
command as we saw previously as part of
the sql tutorial but we're also going to
put if not exists
so if that table does not exist i want
to create a table
and what should we call our table
well i'm going to call it pizzas
so that is what i have chosen to call my
table
next up we need to actually define the
columns and data types that make up our
tables so let's get up our parenthesis
and i'm just going to hit enter to start
this on a new line so it's more readable
and our first column well let's go ahead
and call that something i'm going to
call it pizza id as this is going to
store the pizza id of my pizza
and the data type for this i'm going to
choose use the data type uuid which is a
data type that comes with cql
great
and next the other column is for the
brand of pizza that we're going to have
so once again let's call our column
something which in this case is going to
be brand and i'm going to define the
data type to be text
so in cql we can just write the word
text like so to say that anything in
this column must only be text
great
on to the next column the next column
well i just want to store the actual
name of the pizza so let's go ahead and
call our column name and once again the
data set for this is just going to be
some text so let's go ahead and define
that
next up i'm going to show you how to
work with an array of things so for this
we're going to have an ingredients
column
let's go ahead and call that ingredients
and then if i want to say that i want to
only take
texts but multiple texts i am going to
use the set keyword to do this
so we're going to use set and then using
these brackets i'm going to put in some
text so what i am saying
is that the ingredients column will only
take
an array of texts
great
so that's another data type that we have
just learnt
and next well we are actually going to
want to define how we search for rows in
our pizzas table and i'm going to say
that we are going to be able to search
for the pizzas by their pizza id
and to do this we need a primary key so
i'm going to use the primary key
command
and just pass through the pizza id into
parenthesis to make sure that our table
knows that this is the value we can
search our tables by that will bring
back the whole row
great and of course finish off the
statement with a semicolon and just hit
enter
so wonderful we have just defined our
pizzas table
let's just check that has worked so i'm
going to use the desc command
followed by the key space command and
then the key space we want to describe
and then we just finish this off
and wonderful so there we can see how we
have defined our table
that is working the next thing i want to
do is of course stop putting stuff into
the table
so let's carry on
now to start putting stuff into the
table we're going to have to use the
command insert into
so let's go ahead and use the insert
into command and of course we want to
insert something into the pizzas table
so let's get that up
and actually we are going to have to
tell this
console exactly which columns that we
want to put stuff into
so i'm just going to pick all of them
i'm going to pick the pizza id column
the brand column the name column and of
course the ingredients column and not
finish this off yet i'm just going to
create a new line so it's more readable
we are next going to use the values
keyword in order to insert values into
those columns
now we can of course write our own
unique identifier or we can use a
function so i'm going to use a function
for this and it will randomly generate a
uuid for us so i'm just going to use the
function uuid and call it
next up well we know that the brand
column only takes strings or text so i'm
just going to go ahead and put in the
string of etzkis as the brand
the name is going to be a pineapple
pizza so once again we need to specify
this as a string as we have said that
this column takes text
and next up we need the ingredients so
to put in the ingredients i'm just going
to get up some curly braces this time
and make sure that everything we put in
here is separated by commas and as text
so once again we need to make sure that
they are strings so i've just put in
pineapple cheese and ham
and now we can finish off this statement
great now let's check if that has worked
to check if this has worked i'm going to
use another command yet another command
and this time it is select
so i'm going to select all
this star means all i'm going to select
all from the
table that we called pizzas
and then you guessed it finish this off
with a semicolon and that will bring up
our table with the data as you will see
a unique identifier has been generated
for us it's in green this is also the
primary key okay as we did specify that
when we were describing our table and of
course we've got the brand we've got the
ingredients and we have the pizza name
wonderful
shall we put in something else into our
table i think we should so to do this
i'm actually just going to press the up
button this will bring up the last
commands that we wrote and i'm just
going to get the insert into command up
and all i'm going to do is just switch
out some of the values
so we are going to switch out the
brand of the pizza and i'm going to
switch that out to be pizza hut again
making sure that that is a string of
course we can leave the uuid function as
it was that will generate a new
unique identifier for us
the next thing we need to do is change
the pizza name so i'm going to change
this to be
barbecue pizza just like so and on the
ingredients i'm just going to switch
these up too so we can have a few
different while keeping maybe one the
same so beef and barbecue sauce
great
so let's check that has worked once
again i'm just going to press the up
command to select all from pizzas
and tada we can now see two we can see
two pizzas in our table this is looking
wonderful
now before moving on i just want to put
one last row in so just bear with me
once again i'm just going to press the
up
button so that we can get up the command
that inserts into the table pizzas and
once again i'm going to keep the uuid
function there so it can generate a new
unique identifier for us
i'm going to change the brand name of
the pizza to make it another notable
pizza brand this time is ristorante i'm
also going to change the name of the
pizza this time to be a broccoli pizza
for all of you broccoli fans out there
and of course in the ingredients we are
gonna have to put some broccoli in there
we're also gonna put some mozzarella and
let's also put some corn okay
so
lovely pizza make sure that is all
strings and hit enter
so now if we get the select all from
pizza's command we will see three pieces
in there wonderful that's a lot more for
us to work with let's move on
now
i can write a command that will select
a certain pizza from the table based on
the id
and to do this we are going to use these
select all from pizzas commands
so select all from pizzas but we're not
going to use the semicolon we're not
going to finish this off quite yet let's
make a new line i'm going to use the
where command
so where is another command where the
pizza id so we're getting the column
name equals
the
id of well if we want this pizza right
here the pineapple pizza to come back to
us so the whole row to come back to us i
would just simply grab the unique
identifier and hit enter after the
semicolon and that will bring back
just the pineapple pizza in our table
okay so if you ever need to just get one
row from your table that is how to do it
using the where command just like we did
previously
great
okay so that was a quick crash course in
cql please do not be fooled as i said
there are so many other commands you can
do you can become really complex with
these commands here just a few to your
disposal we are not going to go into
this as i said at the beginning of this
tutorial this is just a basic overview
so you get the idea between writing
relational databases with sql and making
a wide column non-relational database
with cqr there are plenty of courses on
both of these languages on free codecamp
so if you want to take things a step
further please refer back to the
beginning of this course for the video
you need to watch
now the next non-relational database
type we're going to look at is the
document database type
document databases are popular with
mobile apps content management games
some iot scenarios anywhere where you
aren't quite sure how your data is going
to be structured
they don't require joins as they use
hierarchal collections of denormalized
data where fields can be indexed
popular open source options here are
things like mongodb couch base and
couchdb
so wait i don't have to decide how my
data is gonna be structured that sounds
great so why wouldn't i use that all the
time for everything
well ideally data should be as
structured as it can be
you'll pay a price down the road when
you want to join it troubleshoot data
type conversion errors and so on
more strongly type data and data
modeling better defines your app to
database interactions which lower
overall cost
for example data modeling consumes a
fraction of the overall developer time
in a project and can have a large impact
on code quality
data modeling catches errors and
oversights early when they are easy to
fix
this is better than fixing errors once
the software has been written or worse
yet is in customer hands
however
document or document orientated database
types are arguably the easiest types to
deal with from the perspective of
development because they require no
schema in contrast to models like
relational and white column that
requires schema before they can be used
by an application developer
before in the table we made so in other
words the wide column database we had to
define the column that made up our table
as part of that upfront schema
definition process
with document databases we don't have to
do any of that as long as our data comes
as an object it's fine the objects are
made up of keys and values and look like
this
this is an example of perhaps an item
you might find on a to-do list
the values can be strings numbers
booleans arrays or even objects
themselves this is called json or
javascript object notation and is the
most popular format for document
database types
now a group of documents is called a
collection we will not be using the word
tables anymore it has now been replaced
by collections
keep that in mind moving forward
now what are we waiting for let's get to
it in this next section i'm going to
make a collection of pizzas using the
document api but why not a query
language well using api like rest
graphql or json may already be familiar
to many app developers so it reduces
some of the learning curve
now for those of you who haven't heard
of the term api let's do a quick crash
course
an api stands for application
programming interface they allow
developers to enable technologies to
essentially talk with each other and are
essential to so many automated services
that we rely on today they are behind
most apps that we use on a day-to-day
basis and can shape the information
passed between one technology to another
they can even connect things such as our
cars fridges or pens to the internet
apis are everywhere
as a developer you might use the twitter
api to get live tweets on your site a
map api that will allow us to get data
from a third party to use in our new
delivery app we are building or even use
them in a two-way stream to get post or
delete data from a customer relationship
management system for example
there's a reason why these words are
popping up and let's go into why
in this next section you are going to be
seeing these words and using them to
communicate with the database you make
in this context they are called http
request methods
the most common are the get request post
requests
put requests and delete request there
are others too but for the sake of the
tutorial these are the ones you need to
know get essentially gets data and
that's it so imagine you have a client
or in other words your computer and a
server
you are on your computer and the url
which is where you want to get your data
from is on a server the client so once
again your computer
sends an http get request to the server
to retrieve the data we want
so here we have a get request or a
visualization of a get request the
client is requesting that the server
gives it the necessary resources
that we need
then after the server has sent the
response
so request and response
we say that we've got it
thank you
after the server sends the response it
closes something called a tcp or
transmission control protocol connection
we also have post requests and put
requests so here we have a visualization
of how the requests would work with post
requests so simply sending something to
the server and with put requests which
are the same we are sending something to
the server but essentially with the put
request we are sending something to edit
something that already exists or in
other words overwrite it and of course
we also have the delete request which
will delete an existing piece of data on
the server so to get interacting with
our data you will see these different
endpoints
simply put an endpoint is where a
resource lives so with this
point here forward slash burgers
i could get all my burgers i can also
create a new burger and add it to my
existing burgers with this endpoint
right here forward slash burgers making
sure it's a post request to create a new
one i can also edit a singular burger i
would do so by defining the id of that
particular burger in an end point that i
have chosen and make sure that this is a
put http request
and finally the same for delete i would
identify the individual data by writing
a url that also has the identifier in it
and make sure this is a delete http
request
okay so now that we've got that let's
get to actually using this information
in practice with a tutorial
so once again on the data sags astro
dashboard where we can see our key
spaces in the tutorial database well
we're going to have to create a new key
space so let's go ahead and click on the
add key space button to the right
and then that should bring up
a panel in which we can name our new key
space
so i'm going to name this document so
that can show you how to work with
document types
okay
so great if we refresh this it should
show up right here under the previous
key space that we used
now to
connect to this well i'm just gonna go
to the connect tab
and then i'm gonna choose the document
api to connect to our key space
okay
and to do this we actually have some
swagger ui to make our life a lot easier
and to launch it we just have to click
on this url right here okay so this will
launch these swagger docs for us and
this is super helpful in letting us know
what kind of commands we need to write
in order to add data get data delete
data or edit data okay just by simply
filling out some
inputs okay
so for example if we want to create a
collection so in the previous tutorial
we essentially made tables this time
instead of tables we're going to work
with collections okay so replace table
in your mind with a collection and let's
try it out
so there has been a default token given
for us however if you want to use your
own so the one that you saved at the
beginning of this tutorial or if you've
lost that and want to try another one
you can actually generate a new one so
if you go back here and create a new
token
we're simply going to select a role i'm
going to just do admin and generate a
token so now we can use the default one
or we can use this one so i'm going to
copy that
and then back in here delete this and
just use the one we generated
you are free however to just keep the
default if you wish
so the first input that we can put in is
the namespace or in other words key
space that we want to put our collection
in and we know that this is the nosql
document type key space that we have
just made
so in the docs this is called namespace
but for us in data stacks asteroids
called the key space this is just a
naming difference so keep that in mind
and by filling in these two inputs we
are now able to write a body that will
allow us to name the collection
so to do this we need a name as a string
as the property and the value is going
to be the actual name of the collection
which again i'm just going to choose to
call pizzas
and then once we have that i'm going to
click execute
great
so that has worked we get a 201 response
and if we want to do this outside the
swagger ui a request url has been
generated for us based on the inputs
that we used
okay
great
wonderful so we've created our
collection the next thing we need to do
is add a document to this collection
so once again let's select the correct
endpoint so this is going to be a post
request
to the collection that we just created
by the collection id and let's try this
out so we can populate the inputs to
generate a url for us
so once again let's just paste in the
cassandra token the namespace of the
collection that we want to work in is
called document and the collection id
where we hold our collection pizzas so
let's just put that in here
and now we can create our
document
okay
so
let's go ahead and create our first
document i'm going to
make this have a key of name
and a value of pineapple pizza as a
string okay
so there we go we're kind of working
with the same days that we did before
but i'm going to show you why this way
of working is different the previous way
of working in cql in a bit
so let's go ahead and have the brand as
well
so the brand of this is going to be
pizza hut
okay so just like so making sure to make
all of these strings and make sure to
put all the commas in the correct places
too
we are also gonna have a pizza id so
once again a pizza id and this time i'm
just gonna put some random numbers as
the pizza id just like so so just put in
some random numbers too for this
tutorial
next we're going to have an ingredients
key so once again let's get up the word
ingredients as a string
and this time i'm going to make an array
also of text so i'm just going to put in
some text however you will note we are
not defining that this has to be text
anywhere we are not writing a schema
okay we're simply putting in a document
so
now after i put in some things into my
ingredients
so i'm going to put pineapple cheese and
ham
and just go ahead and click execute
you will see that has worked okay we got
a 201 code the response body has
generated the document id
for this json document
okay in case we ever need it and the
request url has been generated for us
based on the inputs that we put in
great
wonderful
okay so now if i want to bring back all
the documents in our pizza collection i
would get the get request that will
search for documents in a collection
let's once again try this out
so i'm just going to click on the try it
out button
populate these inputs so we know that
the cassandra token goes here
the namespace id well we're working in
the nosql document type namespace or
keyspace and the collection is called
pizzas now if i click execute this will
bring back the document that we put in
this collection at the moment there is
just one document that is the document
id that got generated when we
successfully put in this document into
the collection this is all under data
okay but right now we only have one
document in here
great
okay
so now why this is different to cql well
i'm going to show you now
let's go ahead and go back and create a
new document
so
here is the previous pizza that we put
in or in other words the json document
that we put in
now because we haven't defined a schema
as in we haven't said what kind of key
let's go in here into my object
so this time let's just get rid of
everything in here okay and start from
scratch and this time i'm literally just
gonna have one key value pair okay so
i'm just gonna have the name of a pizza
right because once again we have not
defined how many key party pairs have to
go
in the documents that go into our pizzas
collection we literally didn't do any of
that we can put anything in our pizzas
collection so if i just simply put this
and click execute
okay so that has worked a document id
has been generated for me
and now if i go back to getting all the
documents in the pieces collection so
once again just go back here making sure
to use the get request
and click execute
you will see that's worked now we have
two document ids two documents in here
okay but
two different structures to each one
so hopefully you can see why this can be
problematic for example if i was to be
making a pizza app and decided to
perhaps map the brand names onto
something the cauliflower pizza would be
missing the brand name okay
so that is just something to look out
for when working with the document type
now not only does this apply to you know
the keys but also the data types you can
put any data type under here because
once again we have not specified
anything we don't have any schema
and of course we can also add new key
value pairs so for example i'm just
going to do this one more time i'm going
to create another new document so let's
get our post request to do this to the
collection of pizzas
and i can just go ahead and add a new
key value pair this time i'm going to
choose calories
so calories is the key as a string and
then the value is just going to be
200 okay so not a string and if we click
execute you will see that has worked
and then if we go back and get all the
documents in our pieces collection so
once again i'm just going to run execute
you will see three completely different
document types there is no real
sense or logic to this we're just simply
chucking stuff in there
okay
now let's look at one of the other often
used non-relational databases the key
value store
key value databases are one of the
simplest types of non-relational
database popular examples are things
like memcache redis or etcd
there is no query language native to
this model to learn it's highly similar
to language level data structure so the
key value databases don't need them
key value databases are most often used
as caches but that's not all they're
good for
a creative use case fit here can when
new valuable performance gains over
relational models
so
let's look at key value databases they
look like this
you have a key column and then you have
a value column you can actually have as
many value columns as you wish
the most important thing here is that we
can retrieve data back to us so an
entire row by the key and that is the
identifier in this case
let's have a quick look at an example
rather than switching database platforms
we can use a key value trick and
implement the key value pattern which is
highly similar across databases so let's
see how to apply the key value pattern
using a graphql api but implemented on a
wide column database for example
back here on our astra db interface all
i'm going to do is create a new key
space that we can work in once again i'm
just going to click on the add key space
button what should we call this key
space well let's keep an eye on the
previous one so no sql key value type
please go ahead and call this whatever
you wish
this is what i'm choosing to call mine
and i'm just going to confirm that
great now once that has finished
creating itself i'm just going to
refresh this page in order for it to
show up
we can now connect to it this time i'm
going to choose to connect our key space
using the graphql api just because in
the previous section we did it using the
document api
i'm going to show you how to do it using
the graphql api this time
in order to start adding a table to our
key space i'm going to have to write a
mutation using graphql
to make our lives easier i'm just going
to go ahead and open up the playground
which will help us do all of this
just go ahead and click on this link
right here in order to open up the
playground
now this playground will essentially
help us write our queries and mutations
thanks to the documentation provided
that auto generates based on what we put
in the key space
to access this we're of course going to
have to put in our cassandra token now
we can use the one that has been auto
generated for us or if you wish you can
replace it with the one that you saved
so go ahead and do that or just choose
to leave the one that's there as default
the choice is up to you
then once we have done that we should be
able to check out the docs
just go ahead and click on the green tab
and that will bring up all the
documentation that is to our disposal in
order to help us write our queries and
mutations
great
the first thing we're going to do is you
guessed it create a table
this is the mutation we need it is a
mutation hence it's on the mutations tab
and we're going to use the mutation
create table
just go ahead and write that on the left
in the playground
now if we click on the create table
mutation in the documentation it will
tell us what we can put into our create
table mutation in order to create the
table
the first thing we are going to have to
do is
this is required because we see a bang
here we're going to have to put in the
key space name
let's go ahead and do that
i'm just going to put the key space in
the here in parenthesis
the key space that we want to work with
is of course the key value key space
that we created
go ahead and put that in there as a
string
the next thing we need to do here is put
in the table name this is also required
as you can see here by the bang
so go ahead and put that table name in
here again as a string
we're going to choose to call it pizzas
just to be consistent with everything
we've been doing so far
next what is also required is that we
have a partition key
this functions as a key in the key value
pattern we're implementing here
so once again let's write partition key
according to the documentation this
needs to be an array
it needs to be an array so let's go
ahead and make this an array
the array needs to take a name which is
required as a string and also a type
we're going to have to define the type
that goes in here
the type well we actually have all these
types to our disposal it's essentially a
nice cheat sheet for us but we know that
we're going to have to use the type
basic of uuid
because we've done this a few times
already
a uuid is what we're going to have with
the pizza id it is our choice
we can of course have any from the list
great
once we have defined our table so we
define exactly what the table is going
to be called and what our partition key
is going to be
once again this will function as our key
in the key value scenario we are also
going to have to define some of the
values that are going to go into our
table which of course played the other
value role in the key value pattern
i'm going to say that our table here is
going to have the value of name
the name of this is literally going to
be the string name and the type of this
is just going to be text we are going to
say that our pizza table is going to
have a name and it's also going to have
a brand
we're also going to have another value
in here
this time i'm going to find the string
brand and the type of this the brand is
also going to be the type of text
great
let's go ahead and see if that has
worked
i'm not going to have all the same
columns as we had previously because
there is a lot to learn i'm just going
to show you the most basic form of
creating a table using gql or graphql
we're just going to run this and we
should see create table true we now know
that our table has indeed been created
this is all looking fantastic
great
now that we have defined the schema of
our table we're going to add data to the
table based on the schema
in order to do this we actually need to
change the endpoint
so what i'm going to do is just change
this from graphql schema to graphql
forward slash and then my keyspace name
just go ahead and do that let's get rid
of the mutation we wrote here as well
now if we look in the docs you'll see
the docs have been updated this is a
different endpoint and you will see that
the queries have changed we will now see
the queries to get the pizzas
as well as this you will also see the
mutations have changed
now i have a mutation in order to add a
pizza to my pieces table delete a pizza
or update a pizza and the bulk insert
pizza into my pieces table is also there
wonderful
go ahead and insert our first pizza
for this again i'm going to choose a
mutation the mutation we are going to do
is insert pizzas and then we are going
to have to write this on the left
once again we know this is a mutation so
let's use the mutation keyword
and now let's use the insert pizzas
mutation
once again i'm going to get up our
parenthesis our doctors are actually
helping us do this because it is telling
us exactly what we need to do which
fields or which values are required and
which ones aren't and so on
of course the pizza id is required so
let's go ahead and put in our pizza id
i'm just going to put any random unique
identifier in here as a string
i'm also going to define the name as
that is one of the values that we have
defined in our schema
the name of my pizza is going to be
pineapple pizza
just go ahead and put that in as a
string
it must be a string because we defined
that it must be a string
we're also going to have a brand which
again is going to be a string and in
this case i'm going to put dominoes just
to check this has worked i'm going to
return some values in fact i'm going to
return all the values i'm going to
return the pizza id and i'm also going
to return the name and the brand
this is just the return values to see if
this has worked okay and everything is
working fine we could have just returned
one of the values if we wish
ah we have an error this is because the
pizza id needs to be a certain format
the uuid does not take a certain format
i'm just going to generate a unique
identifier online for us just to make
sure the format is okay and just copy it
and paste it in here like so and click
run
great
we now know this does work because we're
getting the values back we're getting
the pizza id back we're getting the name
back and we're also getting the brand
back this is all looking wonderful
great
we have officially added a pizza to our
pizza table
we can also update the pizza that we
just added in order to do this once
again i'm going to write a mutation i'm
going to use the mutation keyword
we are going to use update pizzas this
time and update pizzas well we're going
to have to update the pizza
we're going to have to search for it by
its unique identifier or in other words
the key in this key value scenario
let's also pass through the other values
we want to change
in this example i want to change the
name
i'm going to pass through the name value
and then i'm just going to change it to
this time to be watermelon pizza
i'm just going to put the string of
watermelon pizza in here like so
if we don't put in any other values that
are associated with this pizza i'm just
going to show you what happens at the
moment i have missed out the brand and
let's just return the values of pizza id
once again i'm just going to return
value and then open up some curly braces
and put pizza id in
i'm also going to put the name of course
and the brand because those two things
are the things that make up my pizza
if i click the button you will see i've
updated the pizza i've searched for the
pizza bites id again your key in this
key value scenario and i've updated the
name to be watermelon pizza but because
i didn't add a brand the brand is simply
no
it's as if you said hey you didn't put a
value for the brand so the band is now
null
great
we are also going to have to add the
brand back in so i'm just going to go
ahead and put the brown back in as a
string dominos that's all i'm doing i'm
putting the brand in as dominoes
great now if we click run again you will
see what our pizza looks like
wonderful
there's one more mutation i want to show
you and that is the mutation to delete a
pizza
to do this once again i'm going to get
the mutation so we can look at the dots
i'm going to get the mutation keyword
and then i'm going to use delete pizzas
once again let's get up our parenthesis
so we can pass the value and we want
this to be the id so the pizza id
i'm just going to pass through the pizza
idea like so and i'm gonna paste it in
so i'm just paste it in the pizza idea
that we created previously
so it's now called watermelon pizza i'm
just gonna return something that we know
this has worked
on this occasion i'm just gonna return
back their pizza id that's all i'm doing
so value pizza id
now if we press this button we would
have deleted the pizza because the value
is returning back
so we now know this has worked
now if i try search for the pizza by
that pizza id i'm going to use a query
this time because we're going to search
for the pizza in our pizzas
i'm going to use the query keyword let's
go ahead and get up our kylie braces
i'm going to use pizzas because that is
what we call the table and then i'm
going to search for the pizza by a value
we're going to have to open up some
parentheses again
we're going to use value and then we're
going to use some kylie braces to search
for the pizza id based on the pizza id
we want to search for
now i'm going to get up my curly braces
and just return back some stuff so we
know what is coming back to us this time
when we search for the pizza by the
pizza id in the pizzas table
once again at this time i'm just going
to put values
curly braces and i want to return back
the pizza id of the pizza we are
searching for the name and the brand
just go ahead and do that and click on
the play button you will see nothing
comes back
this is because we've successfully
deleted the pizza with the delete pizza
mutation from our pizzas table
wonderful
this is looking good
now i'm just going to do one more thing
actually i'm just going to add another
pizza first i'm going to show you that
even though we are adding this data with
gql or the graph query language it is in
our database and we can actually access
it however we want we can even access it
with cql
once again this is some good repetition
for you
i'm going to use the mutation keywords
and i'm going to use the insert pizzas
mutation and open up my parenthesis in
order to enter the values that we want
to enter for our pizza
we're going to have to give it a pizza
id which i'm going to generate
so let's write pizza id and then i'm
just going to generate a uuid for us
later
we're also going to have to have the
name of the pizza we want to insert
on this occasion i'm going to say
chocolate pizza because why not as a
string
we're also going to have to have the
brand so let's go ahead and put in a
chocolate brand so i'm going to put in
lint
now
we're just going to paste in our
generated uuid i just made this one up
and let's return the values
i'm going to return the value of pizza
id
name
and the brand just to check that this
pizza has been inserted and everything
works if we go ahead and press the play
button we will see that it has worked
because the values are returning
if we now go into our astra db console i
want to check that this has worked using
my cql console
how do we do this
well again this is a great refresher to
the cql part of this course
first off i'm going to use the desc
keyword for describing the key spaces
that live in our database you will see
there is a key space we need so there it
is i'm going to use the keyword use in
order to go into this key space
use and the key space name followed by
the semicolons to finish off the
statement and hit
enter
next up i'm going to check that the
schema is the same one that we just
wrote in the graphql playground
to do this i'm going to use the desc
keyword for the described keyword again
i'm going to describe the key space to
see what schema live in it
great
you will see there it is
there is the schema i made we've got the
pizza id we've got the brand and we've
got the name this is looking good we
even know that the piece id is the
primary key
wonderful
now if we select the pizzas table so if
we select everything select keyword all
the star means all from the pizzas table
ta-da you will see our chocolate pizza
that we added using gq app
and we've got the whole table using cql
back to us so we can view it in the cql
console this is looking wonderful
so can most non-relational databases and
even relational databases easily be used
in a key value pattern
sure
however database is used in this way
with a key value pattern as a secondary
model are different from the key value
as the primary or only model for example
like in memcache or redis a key value
primary system is inherently much
lighter weight compared to the other
models as they have simpler or smaller
footprint runtimes compared to the other
non-relational databases
this is why they are so often used for
low-latency high-performance cash use
cases applying the key value pattern to
say a tabular or wide column database
could make a lot of sense
assuming the extra functionality tabula
brings over key value also makes sense
for a majority of the application's code
base and use case
but there will be a limit to the number
of levels deep you can nest key value
pairs
when applying the key value pattern to
document databases such as couchdb and
mongodb that store entire documents in
the form of json objects you can think
of these objects as nested key value
pairs
unlike tabular databases you can nest
key value pairs as much as you want
json also supports arrays and
understands different data types such as
strings numbers and boolean values
coming back to the true key value
databases like memcache or redis they're
a great fit for features like
leaderboards or simple data structures
in an app that need to be in real time
ectd for example is a well-known key
value system built for housing for
distributed app configuration data as a
service in kubernetes making app or api
infrastructure another great use case
for the key value database
multi-model databases are also quite
popular and can perform the role of
multiple nosql database models against a
single integrated backend both
relational and non-relational databases
can be multi-modal postgres and
cassandra stargate provide json document
interfaces atop relational and
tabular-wide columns respectively
there are two main approaches to multi
model you can use a polygot database
architecture or use a multi-model dvms
some examples here are oracle db
offering document graph and rdf
capabilities making it a multi-model
dbms similarly non-relational systems
redis key value store extends its
application scenarios with downloadable
modules into a multi-model dbms and
cassandra added a json document
interface with stargate
some non-relational dbms will build an
inception process different data in
different shapes like orango rendb or
cosmos tb
now let's finish off the course with a
summary of when to use relational and or
non-relational dba messes while no sql
databases have many advantages they're
not the right choice for every situation
sometimes sticking with a tried and true
sql database is the way to go
summing all up here are some good
reasons to use or stay with an rdbms or
relational database management system
if these are true it may not be worth
switching
instead augment existing apps with nosql
so in other words adding microservices
is a perfect opportunity you can mix and
match people do it all the time with key
value caches and rdbms's
try graph for fraud detection wide
column or tabular for your app or api or
the document database for content
management
however if you know your operational
database needs low latency at high load
big or unbounded data sets
global or regional deployment or
replication flexible data modeling and
high availability as well as handling
global scale at lower costs one of the
available nosql stores is a great choice
when you are considering migration for
example to a wide column nosql store
ensure that you understand the
differences between normalized and
denormalized data understand your
application ui and data access layer
code build an entity relationship
diagram adapting your data model define
your access patterns grouping data
together wherever possible design your
primary keys and indexes and plan
deployment and move data
it's a similar story when migrating to a
document database you'll need to adapt
your data model to documents collections
fields and more adapt your application
code plan your deployment and move your
existing data
we've compared sql and nosql databases
across several factors and giving you
plenty of places to continue your
learning spend the time to think about
how each would apply to your data
profile and use cases and best of luck
thanks for watching and see you again
soon
you